par rapport aux logiciels
alors j'ai l'impression que vous
affirmez que c'est une évidence et une
réalité premièrement ça n'a pas été
démontrée je le rappelle il s'agit d'un
collectif de journalistes
si on remonte le financement de ces
collectifs on trouve des fondations bien
connus comme d'open society comme la
sunlight foundation qui est créée par le
même fondateur que d'open society c'est
à dire jours chauds roche qui d'ailleurs
se qualifier de chef d'état sans état et
donc on n'est pas dans une logique de
neutralité journalistique norme est dans
une logique de projet idéologique de
sociétés ouvertes qu'elles de telles que
théorisée par porter et dont la finalité
est effectivement et de piocher dans les
différents éléments fournis par des
lanceurs d'alert ce qui permet de mettre
à mal la souveraineté d'un certain
nombre d'états qui seraient pas
suffisamment ouvert aux capitaux
étrangers pas suffisamment intégré à la
doxa dominante libéral postmoderne et
c'est donc en est loin de pouvoir
affirmer que le de jcb gaz et ça a été
effectivement utilisé par le maroc et je
rappelle que l'état marocain a porté
plainte quant au journal l'humanité mais
également d'autres journaux par rapport
à cette affaire là parce que ça relève
tout simplement de l'asie la nation je
ne dis pas que ça n'a pas eu lieu je ne
dis pas que le maroc n'utilisent pas ou
qu'ils utilisent je dis que ce n'est pas
démontrée et que peut-être qu'il serait
plus prudent de parler au conditionnel
davantage que d'affirmer que le maroc a
espionné tel ou tel individu alors que
je rappelle que s'il ya un pays qui
espionné tous les chefs d'état d'europe
occidentale c'est bien des états unis ce
qui avait été révélé par snowdon et là
par contre on n'a pas eu la même
réaction que par rapport au maroc là où
par contre c'est pas fondé du tout on a
eu deux petites indignation à l'époque
d'hollande et d'autres chefs d'état là
où c'était pourtant prouvé est avérée
[Musique]